a huge thank you to Amazon Prime video
for sponsoring this video when it is
this Lake of you a digital afterlife to
which you can upload your consciousness
after you die
free preview click now Hey
I'm sorry Justine what's going on thanks
for your interesting upload oh my gosh
is this is this actually is this lot are
you this is the digital afterlife so
what you're there right now you're
actually in use your inside leg view I
mean to be honest with you I'd rather be
alive but this is pretty cool too I just
thought this was an email anyway I
didn't think was actually gonna be real
hi uh um I'm just seeing what's it like
over there I mean I've been looking into
the program and I have this opportunity
to kind of hop in and just check it out
to get like a little preview you won't
have full access but you know you can
check out some of what we have to offer
I will tell you the breakfast buffet is
killer there's something called the
memory parlor which is really cool they
can take any memory from your past and
projected on screen in front of you a
little movie well my biggest concern
that was like I mean right now just with
my regular phone like I'm always going
over my data plan so I was looking
through the different options and I saw
there was one like the lowest here is
like a two gig I mean I use 16 gigs on
my phone yeah you do not want to get to
the gate if you use it that much that in
the real world you're gonna use a lot
more when you're here so I would go for
the biggest data plan that you can have
I got uploaded to my girlfriend's plan
and you know she has unlimited data but
I have to get everything cleared before
I purchase it so it's not the best so
your girlfriend though she's in the real
world there are things called hug suits
and that she can use that to come in to
upload and steamy physically then she
can just leave and I'm kind of stuck
here but you know things could be worse
I could be old-fashioned real dead
well when you were in your real life
before like all of this happened I mean
what was your job like can you still
work they don't want you know dead
people or AI taking real people's job so
there's no actual career
our jobs here but before I uploaded my
my friend and I were working on a
version of upload that people could have
within their families and just passed
down from generation to generation
they were enticing me with the game mode
I feel like they're doing some really
specific targeting advertising towards
me it's unreal so if you turn on game
mode all of the AI that are there to
normally help you like the bellboy etc
they turn into monsters and you can play
first-person shooter you can play Street
Fighter X game it's it's actually
previously yeah I click this link and
you know you're technically working for
the company so any downfalls that I
should be aware of well I actually think
the downfalls help make it feel more
like real life you know it's not a
utopia it's definitely not a dystopia
it's kind of this middle topia I
definitely miss being in the real world
but this is its own world with with with
highs and lows and ups and downs so if
you didn't know that you're uploaded
would you know that you were uploaded
does that make any sense
definitely not right away but you know
you'd end up seeing little things that
would probably start to tip you towards
that I mean it's much more beautiful
here than it is you know back in the
real world the colors are more vibrant
but there are little glitches as well
like the water is essentially a
repeating gift I mean how big is this
place like do you run into same people
all the time just think of it as a world
with a bunch of fours you'll see the
same people from your floor but you can
go to one of other thousands of floors
that will look similar both have
different people I'm so nervous I don't
even know I mean do I guess I'll have to
worry about what I'm wearing because I
can choose my outfit when I get there
right anything you want don't go near
the BitTorrent the torrid what's that
it's the digital stream from the real
world to upload and if you jump into it
you don't get to go back to the real
world
okay just kind of a vlog or something a
little bit all right well I'm about to
head in thank you so much maybe I will
see you there I mean hopefully not too
soon that's kind of that's kind of
graphic this is weird because you're not
really alive and I am this is so strange
I'm so sorry well I hope you're at least
having to do a great
I'm doing a great time you're gonna love
it have fun don't go near the torrent
okay I'll see you in the upload bye
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't really upload my consciousness
this isn't real but while I was having
that conversation with nathan AKA robbie
amell who plays Nathan I was almost
convinced that this was something that
is real I didn't get a chance to chat
with Nathan bravi afterwards so this was
our chat we were just chatting and I was
actually convinced that you were there
so this is really insane watched too
many episodes I did it's really good I
got a preview of it and it's it's
awesome so how long were you guys
shooting this for the pilot back in
January of 2018 we shot the first season
in February March and April 2090 and
then now we'll premiere I love the show
I think it's really interesting I think
Greg Daniels who created Parks and
Recreation in the office who created the
show is a genius I think the show is
really funny and weird
I think weird is a great way to describe
the whole concept of it when I
originally heard it I was like wow like
this is not too far off from potential
reality which is kind of crazy to think
about yes comfrey since we since we
started to kill me thanks Robbie for
being in my video and a huge thank you
again to Amazon Prime video for
sponsoring this video if you guys want
to check out upload the des streaming
now on Amazon Prime video I put a link
in the description and I would love to
hear what you guys think of this whole
crazy concept of uploading your
consciousness to the Internet I love it
[Music]